if you want to hear the unknown origins
and abilities of the other mother that
we don't see in the story then stick
around to the end of this video
this lesson is sponsored by audible the
beldam is the dreaded seme tryst that
inhabits a realm used for luring and
unsuspecting children to feast on their
souls
welcome to horror history last episode
we talked about the history of Coraline
Jones so today I'll be covering her
antagonists the other mother also known
as the velvet the story keeps the Beldon
mostly shrouded in mystery but it does
leave little clues that we can use to
learn more about the creatures past its
distinctive capabilities and moreover
its purpose in the twisted world that
calls home so who is the beldum and how
did it come to be in order to understand
let's take it back hundreds of years to
the origin of the other mother it's
never explicitly stated how old the
beldum is but we can determine that by
studying the souls of the victim she
captured it seems she has been luring in
children for hundreds of years if not
more
perhaps her oldest victim is a little
boy whose ghost is discovered by
Coraline when she's locked behind the
mirror when he first sees Coraline he
asked art thou art thou alive the phrase
is derived from Old English and its
usage started to decline in the 17th
century when Coraline asked if he's a
boy or a girl he can't remember but he
says he used to wear skirts but believes
that he was a boy he may be speaking of
a style called the breaching where boys
younger than eight would be dressed in
articles of clothing known as breeches
and that practice was most common from
the 1500s to the early 1800s I
researched the year-by-year usage of
some of the other words that the boy
uses like governess taint scullery and
peradventure and determined that the boy
most likely lived between 1700 and 1760
it is possible that the beldum is older
than that but the boy is her first known
victim the word beldam as we know it
today actually goes back to the 1660s
and refers to an old woman or witch a
possible clue about the nature of the
bell domes powers having something to do
with witchcraft the stone that miss
[ __ ] and miss forcible give Coraline to
help combat the danger that she might
encounter is a Nadder stone which is
also known as a hag stone or witch stone
Coraline uses its magic to find the
souls hidden by the Bell wound so it
would make sense that a witch artifact
would be needed to combat against a
witch additionally the Adderstone is
said to be made from the head of a
serpent
the word adder usually refers to a type
of snake if
has many spider-like properties
including the final form which we see
being an arachnid creature and spiders
are said to be afraid of snakes at least
that's what Harry Potter taught me just
an ancient creature we spiders fear
above others which is our option
portrayed with the ability to transform
into an animal form so it makes sense
that the other mothers true form is a
spider it seems that the beldum has the
ability to take almost any form at once
so it's possible that it only took the
spider form at the end because Coraline
is afraid of spiders however some of her
more intrinsic attributes point to her
true form being a spider which I will
point out as we go through her story
for example the beldum has been living
in this other worlds for hundreds of
years and using it to lure end kids so
she can steal their souls which at one
point scan paired how a spider weaves
its web to catch her flies it's never
explicitly stated why she needs these
kids Souls but according to the cat she
wants something to love I think
something that isn't her she might want
something to eat as well it's hard to
tell with creatures like that so it
seems she needs to lure in these
children so that she can eat them or
possibly capture their souls and slowly
feast off them for hundreds of years at
the time that Cora lines family moves
into the house the beldam is captured at
least three of these Souls her world
looks to be anchored to this one
particular house because all of her
victims seem to be kids who lived there
she doesn't seem to have the ability to
travel and seek out new victims which
may explain why she's so desperate to
capture Coraline she also has the
ability to manipulate her world to make
it more attractive to the kid that she's
trying to abduct when Coraline moves in
she gets to work creating the perfect
world so that Coraline will want to stay
there forever she seems to be able to
fabricate her own realities but she
couldn't truly make anything she only
had the ability to copy and distort
things that already existed so she
spends two weeks studying Cora lines
behavior and building the world that
consisted of three Wonders designed to
entice the young girl like a theater
that performs amazing and thrilling
displays to counter the boring old
ladies downstairs a spectacular mouth
circus in place of a strange man living
above the Joneses and a home with
delicious food and attentive parents as
opposed to core lines real home where
her parents were always busy and the
meals rarely cater to her palate the
beldam builds a gateway between the two
pockets of reality behind a blocked-off
doorway to another flat that his peak
scorelines interest upon discover
there were other ways in and out of this
world which were used by the cats but we
never end up seeing any of them when the
illusion is ready the Belgium uses her
magic to invade horror lines dream
making her see dark shapes that gather
under the moon and sing probably to make
her dreams seem more interesting than
her reality and make her appreciate the
Otherworld even more one day Cora lines
curiosity gets the better of her and she
swipes the key to the unused door and
opens it to find the passageway on the
other side of which she meets her other
mother she is described as being taller
and thinner than her real mother with
paper white skin longer teeth shiny
black hair that drifts as if blowing in
a wind or a current and large black
buttons in place of her eyes she tells
Coraline to go get her other father who
is another creation of the Beldon it
does seem that there are other life
forms in this world but they're
completely at the mercy in control of
the other mother the other father is the
first example but he doesn't have the
same origin as the other mother it seems
that he's more of a featureless blank
slate life-form that she had formed and
manipulated to look and act like or
aligns father and she's given him a
black button eyes to sell the idea that
the two of them are a couple just like
Cora lines real parents
the fact that the other mother sews
together these creations is another
example of her similarity to spiders who
weave webs using strength which they
also used to wrap up their victims the
beldam is the only life form of her kind
in the Otherworld but there are two
other entities lurking in the dark whose
origins have never fully been elaborated
on until now if you want to fully
experience the dark twisted world of
Coraline the best way to do it is by
listening to the audio book on audible
the audiobook is narrated by Cora lines
legendary author Neil Gaiman I love
listening to the story and knowing that
every line is being told exactly the way
the author intended but I use audible
for so much more than just diving deeper
into Coraline pretty much any book you
can think of has a narrated version on
audible but that's far from the extent
of their offerings you can also listen
to podcasts comedy performances audible
originals that you'll never find in
print and so much more what I love about
the service is that it can be so hard to
find time to read a book in today's
world but thanks to audible you don't
really have to it's great for me when
I'm making these videos because I don't
have to stop every time that I want to
take notes I can just have it continue
reading while I'm typing and when I'm
listening to a title for fun I can turn
it on in the car while I'm cooking while
I'm exercising
sometimes even while I'm working and I
get to hear so many greats
that I never would have had the time for
before just visit audible.com slash
Jeezy's world or Tex Easy's world of 500
500 I'll leave the link for you in the
description
again that's audible.com slash Suzie's
world
[Music]
the other mother and other father tell
coralline that everyone has a second set
of parents and this is all part of the
like reiated by the other mother to make
Coraline feel comfortable staying in the
other world
she sends Coraline up to play with the
rats in her bedroom the rats are
basically like henchmen that do all of
the other mothers bidding they entertain
Coraline and stack on top of one another
to give a humanoid form to the clothes
of the man upstairs at first she thinks
this is simply the other mr. Bobo just
as she has an other mother and an other
father but by the end of the book it
becomes clear that the other mother
doesn't have someone to play that role
it's actually just a group of mice
pretending to be a person but there are
two more human looking other forms that
Coraline encounters in the Bellman's
world which she encounters when she goes
downstairs to check out the theatre that
has replaced the flat of miss [ __ ]
and miss forcible poor line learns that
the performers did not actually look
like old ladies when they take off their
fat suits and reveal thin young women
with black but knives these would be the
last two human characters with buttons
sewn over their eyes so we have the
other mother who is the shape-shifting
Beldon herself the other father who
doesn't actually look like Coraline
father and these two women who are
actually just wearing costumes to make
them look like [ __ ] enforceable so who
are these other life-forms living in the
beldon's domain we know that the other
mothers goal is to eventually sew
buttons over Coraline XY's so what if
these other people being manipulated by
her are the bodies of the children that
she abducted over the years the idea
makes sense because there were only
three of them two female and one male
and we later find that the kids Souls
have been removed from their bodies and
they continue to exist only as ghosts
who can no longer remember what they
were like in life while Coraline is busy
inside the theater the other mother
returns to the real world and kidnapped
scorelines parents she imprisons them
inside of a snow globe and hides it away
on the mantle in the drawing room of the
Otherworld
at the end of Cora lines visit to the
theatre her other parents greet her
outside of the house and make the offer
to let Coraline stay forever if she can
sew the buttons over her eyes Coraline
promptly tells them that she'll be
leaving now and her other mother's hands
scuttled off Coraline shoulder like a
frightened spider they tell her to come
back soon and she leaves the other
mother seals back up the doorway likely
to like horror lines anticipation of
returning to that world builds before
she reopens it eventually Coraline
returns to the Belden's world to try to
find her parents and the other mother
tells her that her parents were bored of
her and it is here that we learned of
another magic ability that she possesses
for the purposes of deceit and
manipulation she's able to brush her
hand against the mirror and create an
image of Coraline
real parents they appear to be going on
vacation without their daughter and
boasting about how nice it is not to
have Coraline weighing them down
Coraline doesn't fall for the false
image so the other mother results to a
less psychological tactic by having one
of her rats run into the real world and
steal the key to the doorway so that
Coraline can not get back out the other
parents go to bed commenting on how
they'll need their beauty sleep if they
aren't gonna have a midnight snack I'm
guessing that snack was supposed to be
Coraline and this is the first
suggestion of the idea that the other
mother needs to eat in order to keep
using her powers or spells there's some
evidence of this the next day when
Coraline wakes up and goes into the
other father's study and he's just
sitting there not doing anything at all
she also thinks he looked less like a
true father today there was something
slightly vague about his face like bread
dough that had begun to rise smoothing
out the bumps and cracks and depressions
the other mother is out in the garden
during this time working on patching up
the other passageways that exist between
the real world and the other world so
that the cat could not freely travel in
and out the other mother does not like
the cat and sees him as a vermin I think
this is because she's afraid of him in
his wits and going back to the idea that
her true form is a spider
cats eat spiders so it makes sense that
she'd want to keep him out the cat
claims that there are passages that the
other mother doesn't know about other
mother next encounters Coraline as she's
returning from a walk and offers to play
a game which reveals another important
trade of hers her love of games it is
likely that she loves games because her
primary target seemed to all be children
it seems like she easily could have sewn
buttons over the eyes of Cora Lions
parents but elects not to probably
because they have no nutritional value
to her she's also a notoriously
excellent way for her to strike deals
with her victims and cheat her way into
winning them Coraline doesn't fall for
the idea of playing a game on the other
mothers terms so the other mother tries
to convince her to stay again casually
eating beetles as she does sell their
cocoa beetles from Zanzibar this is the
only thing we actually see the other
mother eating during the novella she
doesn't eat any of the real food that
she prepares for Coraline and it
represents the metaphor of how she wants
to consume Coraline soul and the beldam
needs that soul to continue to thrive
unable to get anywhere with Coraline she
gets upset and claims that Coraline has
lost her manners by refusing to cave in
to her demands and locks her in the area
behind the mirror as punishment and
keeps her there until the following
morning during this time Coraline meets
the ghost children which teaches us more
about what
happens when the Belden takes your soul
the victims have forgotten their own
names and identities they are only able
to remember trivial details about their
lives and the feeling of the other
mother taking their lives their joy in
their hearts and leaving them hollow
while coralline is locked away the other
mother scolds the creature that she had
created to play the role of the other
father foretelling coralline to much she
strips him of any remaining identifying
features and discards him in the dark in
the cellar below the abandoned flat next
door she locks in there and swallows the
key the next morning she retrieves
Coraline and brings her to the kitchen
table for breakfast hoping today that
she would finally be able to break her
but Coraline would surprise her with a
challenge in a scene that teaches us yet
another secret about the true nature of
the Belva Coraline challenges the other
mother to a game of hide-and-seek if she
can locate the souls of the dead
children and her parents the other
mothers to let her leave this world
other mother never planned on keeping
her word even though she swears on her
mother's grave to go through with it we
don't know if a creature like the beldam
actually has parents of its own or a
grave though so this could be relatively
meaningless poor lion seems privy to
that fact so she also swears on her
right hand I think this is a strategic
move by the other mother there are many
references to her spider like hands
throughout the story her hand is caught
in the closing door causing it to break
off of the arm and it continues to crawl
around with the mind of its own
what if the beldum is actually just this
hand we know that she has the ability to
create false worlds and false people so
it's possible that the arms torso legs
neck and head were all just for show to
give Coraline a false sense of security
so she had no issue betting on her
mother's grave because she likely
doesn't have a mother and no issue
betting on her right hand because that
would really just be freeing her from
the rest of her body after making the
deal the other mother disappears until
four-line has found two of the three
souls of the Lost Children with each
soul found the world flattens loses its
form and contorts the once bustling
theater becomes abandoned in Dara
leagues I think without the possession
of those souls which she slowly feeds
off of her power she's unable to keep up
the illusion of a perfect world that she
had set up she starts to fear that
Coraline will find all of the souls and
appears again to throw her off course
she regurgitated the key to the empty
flat and implies that Coraline will need
it in order to find the final soul which
is of course a lie but Coraline goes to
investigate it anyways
inside Coraline comes across a giant
dead spider in the bathtub we don't have
any information on any other
possible members of the beldum species
but I have to wonder if this is what
happens when one of them doesn't get the
children souls to feed office in the
basement she encounters the thing that
was once the other father and the other
mother seems to be influencing his
actions trying to get him to hurt for
Rani child leave this place she wants me
to hurt you to keep you here forever so
that you can never finish the game and
she will win she is pushing me so hard
to chew I cannot fight her more nervous
than ever the other mother sends her rat
spies to go retrieve the final soul from
where it's hidden upstairs but Coraline
is able to retrieve it and confront her
back in the drawing room other mother
plans to trick Coraline into forfeiting
the soul but Coraline tells her she
thinks she knows where her parents are
hidden in the passageway between the two
worlds other mother opens it to show her
that she was wrong which would prove her
to be victorious and earn her the right
to sew buttons over Coraline dies but
when she turns back the cat's is flying
through the air towards her face it
scratches an attack sir just long enough
for Coraline to slip into the passage
the beldam screams out no in an inhuman
voice and reaches out to stop the
closing door but it pinches her wrists
and severs her hand which i theorize
could be the real form of the Belva the
hand crawls around core lines world in
search of the key so that it would not
forever be locked out of the other world
where the rest of its body remained that
night it was unable to get in the core
lines room and instead he goes
downstairs to the flat of miss [ __ ] and
miss forcible and attacks one of their
dogs leaving a long gash in his side the
next day
Coraline came to visit the old ladies
and the hand heard her say that she'd be
playing out beyond the old tennis court
and realized that she would have the key
with her to be honest I'm not sure how
it heard what she said because the last
time I checked hens don't have ears but
the point is it secretly followed her to
the spot where it knew she would be
alone it arrives to find a tea party
with Korra lines dolls set up on a
platform with the key in the center when
it went to go steal the key it realized
that the picnic blanket was on no
platform at all and it was stretched
over the top of an open well in the hand
of the beldum fell into its depths
before Coraline sealed the lid once more
it's unclear if a creature like the
beldam would be able to survive such a
fall or how long it would survive until
the next person comes along and opens
the well it does seem reasonable that if
it did survive it would be able to scale
the wall like a spider but it's unlikely
that anyone would open the well again
for several years
the beldum is a mysterious but
horrifying creature it reminds me a lot
of the creature from it from its
shape-shifting abilities to its final
form as a spider from its need to feed
off of young children in order to
sustain itself another Stephen King
connection relates to the shine in the
actress who plays the young version of
the woman in room 237 is named Lea Belva
and she similarly did the Bell demand
for lion takes a pleasant form to try to
win the love of her victim before
revealing her true nasty self this
two-faced personality is yet another
reason that stop-motion was the perfect
choice to make the film version of
four-line the faces of each character
had to be replaced in order to give them
a variety of expressions and over 15,000
faces were used if you want to learn all
of the secrets hidden within Coraline
check out the playlist on the left and
don't forget to use my link in the
description to listen to the audiobook
over on audible and if you love horror
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new ores every week wring
that death battle for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive